that sounds better um even I can hear it
now that's great um did you hear the did
you hear non's intro no okay I'm gonna
rehash that Qui right you know when I
show my slides I'll it'll okay no needa
but a major maker in this space someone
who's really defining it um geez should
have raised their hand and sorry I
should have should have checked uh rainy
arenson Frontline the the woman who
makes it all happen there and the person
who's been really redefining their whole
remit uh bringing it into the digital
age moving it across platforms across
Publixs and across organizations and
she's also a fellow has been a fellow at
our open dock lab here at MIT um next to
Rainey is Casper zonan um someone I've
known for a real long time uh Casper uh
is the is a is a festival organizer and
curator and he founded the doc Lab at
Ida International documentary Festival
uh Amsterdam and this really is the
place The Cauldron the the the place
that's defined more than any anywhere
else that I know of the the whole genre
I guess of interactive and immersive
documentary so Casper is someone who's
really always looking for the ways in
which new technologies meet uh the
documentary form and I have to say
November each November is a treat to
just see what wild and wonderful things
Casper comes up with
um so he knows the field unlike anyone
else that I know and um he's also pretty
energetic in addition to the doc infant
do lab he is also one of the co-founders
of photo stories and also the open air
film festival in Amsterdam so someone
who's a curator to the Bone um and
finally next to me Katie Morrison
co-founder and producer at verto which
is a VR studio uh maker of among other
things Ascent uh in the Turning Forest
so one of the one of the real big
innovators in this space uh flown all
the way over from Australia still
probably lunchtime over there huh or is
it midnight um and a woman who's really
um done a lot to bridge the gap between
traditional documentary makers linear
documentary makers because she was one
and the world of VR uh documentation so
someone who really understands the
different affordances of each side the
different manners of Engagement the
different kinds of immersion and affect
that both media are capable of and who's
really done a terrific job at
translating one Community to the other
through her work as much as anything
else so what I thought we'd do tonight
is start with um that's a lot of words
and they sound great but these are
people who make stuff um so I thought
each of them could give a very short
presentation about their work uh we'll
start off with Noni and then following
that have a few questions up here but
please this is really for you this is an
immersive interactive medium so uh par
ex salance here so you guys can think of
your questions we have mics and after a
few rounds of questions after a warmup
up here we'll turn it over to you so non
yeah hi uh you guys can hear me right
just a quick I have to shout out to
bester cram was in the audience here
tonight who has worked with me on many
of my documentary films and taught me so
much about documentary film making that
I was able to bring into the virtual
space so it's really an honor not only
to be here in MIT but so somebody who's
one of my great mentors is in the
audience so the first piece one of the
first earliest walk around virtual
reality pieces I ever did was called
hunger in Los Angeles I was working as a
research fellow at the University of
Southern California's journalism school
and they were doing a kind of what I
consider a traditional piece now uh with
photos and video and audio all up on the
web and I asked the students in the
class you know I really want to make
this vrp anybody want to do it so um
knowing this was published in uh March
of 2010 by the the way so um this is
many months before this and um nobody
had raised their hand I think they all
thought I was nuts so actually I found
another intern from another place a a
high school student who was graduating
and um with my own money uh about 700
bucks um we went out and started
recording audio at food banks across Los
Angeles um until one day she was at this
long line and a man with diabetes who
was standing there didn't get food in
time and he collapsed into a diabetic
coma and she came back back and she
played me the Audio I like oh my God
that's what we have to build with but
again we had no resources so with
virtual humans that were donated as you
can see on the slide we rebuilt the
street to the best of our abilities and
in fact the Photoshop of the street you
can see kind of the gum and stuff on the
street you could have gone and found
that actually on the street that day um
and here's a little video um using that
real audio uh of the walk around
experience that we made there's too many
people there's too many
people
okay
aure so you can see the guy on the right
you know he's wearing the crazy goggles
we were using in the lab at USC and for
him he feels like he's in the room with
that guy right even though the graphics
aren't perfect whatever he's very
careful not to step on the seizure
victim he's looking down at him he's
walking around he's looking at people
talking on the mobile phone
right so that piece gets into Sundance
for January of 2012 this is fall of 2011
now it took quite a while for me to get
my C coating up and become a better
Unity programmer and beg and borrow a
lot of favors to get it made get some
descendant but there's a problem the
only goggles we have are called the wide
five and they're $50,000 a pair and the
and the head of the lab's like you're
not taking those anywhere right right so
what are we going to do so there was
this funny little team of people hanging
out and we started making goggles this
one kid had already been making some
goggles in his garage that's one who's
got his face planted in that mask there
and if you kind of look at the screen if
you look at those little two black dots
those are your eyes and we're trying to
figure out where to put What's called
the ipd where the eyes should go blah
blah blah and a great guy in the back
test tyan who's really unsung anyway we
show up at Sundance with something that
looks like this duct tape goggles right
and I really know how people are going
to behave and this is opening night
right at the
festival oops sorry what do you
think oh you're crying you're crying
China you're crying I'm completely
shocked right but this happens over and
over again people trying to touch the
seizure victim trying to speak to him
take care of him and just as another
little quick look at those goggles
because it's kind of a historical moment
now uh you'll see in the bottom it's
sign Palmer lucky who William mentioned
um nine months later at this point it's
son Dan he's like crashed to my hotel
room and driving the truck back and was
like kind of the intern of the project
N9 months later he starts the Oculus
Rift and two and a half years later he
sell it for two uh$ two billion dollar
to Facebook Okay ends up on Time
Magazine and gives us the most memed
Time Magazine there ever was in
history so in the same time in that lab
there were these guys who were making
what were were called the fovs to go um
and it's and I they were folded up
viewers from mobile phones right um so
again this is back in 2012 so this is me
in in April of 2012 at at Facebook at
event called Tech wrecking for
journalists that was run by uh the
center for investigative reporting and
Google and I'm handing these things out
and saying really really their future
you can kind of tell from my beady-eyed
look I swear it's the future but um then
this fall of course we get the Google
cardboard delivered in millions to
people you know this what showed up at
my house crazy crazy this is four years
later you guys like like nothing right
time wise so four years what's happened
so now I'm going to give you just five
little predictions I think for the
future and I'll move off
stage I think that kinematic virtual
reality in which you walk around will
become the new cinematic I think it will
become the most commonplace thing all
the new headsets coming out the Vive the
Sony Morpheus Oculus they let you walk
around and even things like cardboard
and gear VR are going to have
controllers that are going to let you
move around and UL VR Guru the guy who
helped start Oculus John carac thinks
that positional tracking is going to be
just as important for mobile VR so
that's one thing two scan environments
they're going to be uh really important
how we're going to do them and
supplemented by Google Maps instead of
you uh looking at a flat view or even
Google Earth view you're just going to
be walking down that street you want to
see literally with your goggles on so
how does this sort of thing apply when
we did project Syria um uh let me give
you a little sample of what that was
about
so in order to make said whoops sorry in
order to make that we had to reconstruct
a street in like a Bible and then have
to make it physically right in the
virtual world so having spaces that we
can actually just be made for us we go
oh it happened there and it's already
done for us in Google maps and then we
just put the activity in you know the
action that's going to help all of us
documentarians and journalists be able
to tell our stories in a
volumetric uh kinematic way I'm going to
skip this slide a little behind I'm
sorry uh witness and characters will be
scanned readily um in this story where a
guy was beaten and tased to death by the
uh border patrol um this grainy footage
that that kept
[Music]
uh to find what really happened this man
was 6 of a dozen Patrol officers beaten
Tas to death we took the witness who hid
some of the footage in her pocket and we
brought her in and we scanned her right
in order to make uh a full look likee of
her in the scene and then we put a
motion capture suit on her so she
reenacted
her own memories of the night uh instead
of us asking her questions Well
everybody's phone is going to allow them
to scan people now Qualcomm Intel all
those chips are coming this Summer that
you're going be able to just walk around
somebody and in three minutes have a
scan version of them of course then you
have to animate them which at this point
is still a little bit harder and you'll
be able to scan environments too
wherever you are on the right up there
is Project Tango which is a big Google
project to let you scan things right now
this is the kind of thing that we have
to do when we do a facial capture onto a
uh and an animated model um this is from
a piece we did on what happens to young
women when they Tred to go into health
clinics like Planned Parenthood real
audio you're a you're a
you're a little how about stop
being a you shame on you
start closing your legs start having
some respect for your body maybe your
parents should have aborted you so that
was a like a facial capture of somebody
actually trying to face uh to recreate
the the audio for us um number four how
are we going to stop doing that where
we're trying to replace the the
animation we'll do something called
videogrammetry High Fidelity volumetric
capture in video We Rule the space we
just captured a guy who is part of a
community of um kids who were from the
LBGTQ Community who were thrown out by
their families and if you look in that
green hidden in that green uh screen
area are those little black cameras
there's multiples of them I think it's
like 46 and then they capture in video
from every angle so you can actually
walk around video I know that's sort of
hard to conceive of what that's like but
that is uh ADI is the company we're
starting to partner with and uh in our
partnership with Frontline we've already
begun um a project together using
exactly this technique and finally my
last slide um uh the future I think that
uh after the hollowland where we're
being projected into each other's rooms
um we're actually going to occupy bodies
in two places at once you hear me now
where were playing with that nice to
meet
you Angeles welcome to Barcelona
Barcelona I don't know n if I could ask
you to raise your
arms keep them keep them up because now
we'll show the
robot can you move them a little bit
more up and
down I'm ready to interview you now for
for a few
minutes you're a
journalist you just interviewed a
researcher from Barcelona but in a in a
body of robot what was that experience
like so for me it starts to feel very
natural after a while um occasionally
there some problems with the the eye
movement my head I
but beyond that very
quickly I'm there in Barcelona with you
so next time I come to speak at MIT I'll
be here without being here thank you
very
[Applause]
much
got it
okay maybe I'll just talk for a couple
of minutes and set it
up
is
that
this okay I'll Stand away from the mic
hi is that better so I'm Rainey arenson
as William said from Frontline and um
how many of you guys watch Frontline
documentaries the linear Forum okay
that's a large number do you guys are
you aware that we're doing work in 360
and
VR some of you well that's
understandable so we are are new um to
the world of VR and I would say that um
partnering with Nani has been really
extraordinary for us because we're
moving from um cinematic VR which is
what we've just been trying to figure
out what the right words are for what
we're making right now to volumetric VR
and one of the things that Nani and I
Frontline and emblematic are really
tasked with is looking at some of the
journalism ethical questions that arise
um when we're creating new film making
tools especially when going into a
frameless space like we do with VR and
we can talk about that if you're curious
the other thing for Frontline has been
that over the last couple of years we
have been exploring all sorts of new
visual storytelling tools and I think
the reason for that is that we're
naturally visual storytellers through
and through inside our shop so for us to
look at the new space that people were
creating in to be honest VR was the best
and sort of closest kindred spirit for
me as a film maker I understood it and I
want to explain that because of course
William and Sarah Willis in were kind
enough to um asked me and I begged them
frankly to become a fellow a couple of
years ago in the open doc lab and I can
remember the very early days not
understanding I don't know Sarah maybe
75% of what you guys were talking about
because I'm a linear filmmaker but once
we started to talk about VR I started to
really understand it and I decided that
was really what we should explore so we
look at VR as filmmakers as visual
storytellers and importantly as
journalists and I am convinced over the
last number of months in particular as
the technology becomes more accessible
and the barriers to entry become lower
and that's really important to me
because I'm in public media and I
believe that media should be affordable
I believe people should be able to
experience this without having the entry
point be too expensive I do believe that
this will radicalize and change story
storytelling in the world that I live in
which is the world of Journalism and
journalistic documentary so I wanted to
show you a clip from something that
we've done out of the South Sudan it's
simply just wonderful to look at and we
can talk a lot more as well and I want
to give my colleagues time so I'll show
you this and I'll sit down and we're
here for
questions
[Music]
how many filmmakers does it take to fix
a
film I think we changed the um the
display
there you
go no then we go into this place that's
hysterical there's SP over to
him there you go sit down
too you might want
think you're going to need to fix
[Music]
that
this plane is taking food to remote
villages in South Sudan's Lan
[Music]
swamps it's the rainy season and roads
are washed
[Music]
out the only way to get food here is to
drop it from the
[Music]
sky
okay yeah lights turn the lights on that
would be great
okay
can you hear me guys is my microphone on
yeah okay cool um so thank you for the
invitation and it's a real privilege to
be here in Boston as as uh as William
said I've just come from Australia so
please forgive me if I like doze off or
say something very um unusual during the
course of this evening um it's a long
flight um so basically I'm going to take
you through a little bit about who we
are on what we do I run a independent
Production Studio called vov with um
Oscar rabby who is in the audience here
he's the the creative director and I'm
the producer um we are a very small
independent studio um that comes from
that kind of tradition of of being in
Indie and when I say small there's like
two of us normally there's 12 of us at
the moment but you know we kind of range
in in that very kind of small space um
we uh started vertov in about I would
say we started in 2013 off the back of
um this project here which was um Ascent
which was made primarily well it started
off as a um a master's project that
Oscar was making as an um as a masters
and interactive media and um it is was
finished its first version in 2013 and
went on to kind of have a Premiere in
2014 and took us a lot of places um it
went to Sundance in 2015 and it's kind
of still continuing to have a life it is
actually here at the exhibition um over
the next couple of days for you guys to
see um Ascent is an autobiographical
documentary about Oscar's family and an
event that his father witnessed in 1973
while he was an officer in the um the
Chilean military um which at that time
was a dictatorship um so it is a really
personal story um it's made as a
interactive realtime VR documentary
which is the way that we work um in in
um in contrast to some of the other
people here today um and I think when we
first started to kind of think about how
we were going to do VR we never really
had a conversation about you know all
the different the different options that
we had available to us and and we chose
interactive real time for any particular
reason but in kind of in doing these
presentations and thinking about our
trajectories towards this this position
um I think it actually makes a lot of
sense that we have ended up in the place
that we're in and I just kind of want to
take you through a little bit of that
thinking because I think it's as
important as the technical kind of side
of it um Oscar is a visual artist by
training and I'm I um as William said am
a documentary maker I worked for a long
time in TV um but before I did that I
was actually training to be a historian
because I thought yeah you know I'm
going to make myself a lot of money and
I'll be a historian and then I decided
documentary was more lucrative um
but but you know uh while I was studying
history and I did um my undergraduate
degrees in history and I did a
postgraduate in history as well um I was
really interested in historiography and
um the ideas about um how we ascribe
meaning to events so I was less
interested in you know a very kind of um
a very sort of um fact-based approach to
history as a more kind of interpretive
approach and I think thinking about the
way that we work now that makes a lot of
sense to me that we've ended up in an
interactive format and and doing
realtime VR because um we've both been
very interested in the kind of the space
between um the user of a text and the
text itself and that kind of
relationship so our approach to VR um is
in interactive real time and um it's
also what we're starting to call
operational documentary so we're
interested in the operations that the
user makes that um that tell the story
as much as what happens in front of
their eyes or all around them in the in
the case of VR so I'll show you a little
trailer from um Ascent but as I say it
is here at the um at the exhibition
so hi Dad I'm glad you could see this I
thought the instructions might have been
a bit confusing but here you are so I
guess it
[Music]
worked I want to to send you something
real and odly enough look what I came up
with look
[Music]
around if you stare at certain things
for long enough
enough something
[Music]
happens we're looking back to
1973 right on this spot you have just
been notified of a court marshall taking
place up the
hill
but today I want you to take the time
you didn't take back then and stay with
me for a little
[Music]
longer so from Ascent um we went on to
um to make our next project which has
just been at Tri Becca um it isn't
actually a documentary so I'll just
quickly show you a slide from it to show
you what it is um it's a fiction fairy
tale um which was an interesting project
that again allowed us to work in
interactive realtime VR um and this
project was actually a research project
together with the BBC research and
development department um based on um
their experiments in binaural audio so
our kind of main um investigation in
this in this particular project was how
to turn um that interest in audio into
an interactive mechanic that we were
able to to bring into the experience so
we ended up um creating this quite
beautiful fairy tale um that um where
the main user interaction is in kind of
triggering the soundscape um we are
coming back to the documentary space now
we have a project which is launching at
Sheffield in June um which is a great
project which is a documentary about um
the Easter Uprising in Ireland um with
BBC I wonder
uh again working with a broadcaster
which is I think something that we
should touch on a little bit later on
how how it is for an indvr company to
work with a big broadcaster kind of
finding their feet themselves in VR um
this project kind of comes back to the
sort of the the structure that we set
out in a sentin a way it's based on an
audio recording of a man who was
involved in the uprising um in 1916 he
recorded his memories in um when he was
about 70 years old and put them on a set
tape put them away in a drawer and um
forgot about them and his descendants
found that tape a little bit later on
and um and it came to us in the end um
and that kind of formed the backbone of
the interactive of the experience um so
our job was then to try and tease out
what um what are the operations that we
can kind of put into this experience
that really kind of convey the story of
this guy um so we took that recording
and used it to kind of craft this
experience with where you inhabit his
memories of of that time um and here's
another slide from that one talking
about the things he did and and things
that he perhaps didn't do um just
quickly a little note on how we work um
so this is we work with um a lot of 3D
scanning for our documentaries the fairy
tale project was crafted entirely in um
you know from scratch in in 3D but our
documentary projects um we use a lot of
3D scanning this is a still from the a
production process of ascent which back
in 2013 we were using just Microsoft
connects to scan with um so that's
that's where that started um this is a
production still from the Irish project
where you can see osar using um it's we
use consumer technology we use an iPad
with a an attached 3D sensor so you know
that turns into that's one of the the
finished pieces so we take those 3D
scans and bring them into um a game
engine um and ends up looking like that
um it's quite portable technology this
is one that was made in South Sudan so
um I was going to show you a bit about
the workshops that we also run but I
think I will leave it there and we can
kind of come back to that if we have
time in the
[Applause]
conversation
hello is this working
is um so first of all it's an honor to
be here um next to uh the person who
introduced me to ziga vertov and Sarah
Wallen up there uh who introduced me to
my favorite robot artist uh who was
actually from Mr um
my name is Casper as said and I work at
ITA uh how many of you know
ITA
wow um so it is an international
documentary film festival after all
um it was founded uh 29 years ago uh by
ali dks um and in
2007 um I started a program there called
ITA dock laab uh sort of to explain
uh documentary storytelling in the age
of the
interface um and when we started um this
was I guess some of the buzzwords that
were uh around at that time uh web
documentary a lot of trans media words
that we some of us really would like to
forget at this point
um and we'll probably have the same with
some of the words that we're talking
about today uh around VR maybe in the
future uh in the end what we decided uh
back then to focus on uh because because
we couldn't find a word that actually
made sense uh so we decided to focus on
four main
ingredients um first of all story
interface Digital Data and technology
and as we are a documentary Festival
captured reality in uh whatever form
possible the only thing we didn't focus
on was linear film making
basically um to give you a little a
Hands-On of what type of projects that
we uh look for at the
festival um uh I think she's here
somewhere cat czak one of the I would
say godmothers of interactive
documentary um the highrise project um
so interactive documentaries web series
but also data art like we feel fine uh
made by SE Kar uh from MIT together with
Jonathan Harris uh multimedia
journalism um digital performance art
which I think is not a term used a lot
but I think if we look at early works of
people like Z Frank and Miranda jully
that's that's basically what it is and I
think in 2011 or 10 we had our first uh
VR project um I'll talk a little bit
about this one tomorrow uh at the
conference uh but I just want to show
you one clip um of uh a project by
Alexander rean project that we
commissioned uh in I think 2012 or 13 uh
as an example of I would say sort of
some of the other less web- based
projects uh but projects that involve
robots and biometric uh technology
Etc leave the lights on it's only 30
seconds I'm going to ask you some
questions who Do You Love most in the
world my mom I love my mom my
wife what will people remember you for I
leave czy crazy freaky generous small
tell me something that you've never told
a stranger
[Music]
before we're not going to play that game
now but
um uh we'll go on to what do we do with
these projects um so we look for them we
curate them we select them and
occasionally commission them um but then
we're basically still a festival so
every 10 days or for 10 days every
November um we have a competition
program in the main
Festival um where we actually now have
two Awards a digital storytelling one
and an immersive non-fiction award hey
VR um we organized a 10-day exhibition
uh with installations this is a machine
to be another from B another
lab um we organized live Cinema events
which back in 2008 started as sort of
director navigations where um a director
would navigate through an interactive
program creating sort of a live linear
version um nowadays wow that's bad
resolution sorry uh now we're exploring
much more sort of theatrical and new
types of Life Cinema events uh ranging
from Collective VR screenings uh to this
was our opening night event and actually
some of the people that you see here uh
huddled together are somewhere here in
the room
um uh bonus points if you spot them
um 10
points
um I don't than that we have an annual
conference day we have markets where new
projects get funding we have a talent
program running throughout the
festival um and online we have our
website where I think there's around 200
projects that you can look back to um
today and projects for instance one of
the things I'm most proud of that we
ever did was uh collaboration with with
MIT uh called moments of innovation um
it's slightly dated um up until 2012 I
think but it's totally worth it to go
through it um and I just want to end it
with a few final words as we're um about
to celebrate our 10y year anniversary I
think when we started the program there
was a lot of skepsis around whether the
internet was actually a medium that
could be suitable for art or not um and
I think 10 years later um we got to the
point where I love z uh uh view on on
the internet yes it's good and bad and I
think basically this goes for VR as well
right um so where we are now interactive
documentary uh is growing
up some people know that I always use
cats in
my um but I would say starting from 10
years ago where there was a few people
here and there around the world doing
interactive documentary and stuff that
was so hard to Define I think uh amongst
other thanks to MIT open do lab and some
of the other organizations that were
bringing people together we now have a
small ecosystem yet at the same time I
think as the web has grown up we're also
starting to
realize that the world that we inhabit
has become digitized to an extent that
maybe isn't always great um and we're
sort of having this sort of next wave of
technological breakthroughs with VR sort
of being I think the gateway drug
um to a lot of other things um and I
want to close with uh a quote by
Jonathan Harris one of my favorite
artists in this space um who said a
couple of years ago we speak a new and
Powerful language capable of saying
things no other language can say but few
have realized this and even few even
fewer have found what to say I think
that's the case for interactive
documentary but uh for VR we're we're
not even towards a full language yet and
that's why um we're launching something
new this year which is called the
immersive non-fiction Network which is
um a program where we want to develop
pilot projects want to do uh audience
research and organize events and bring
different people together so if you have
a great idea for a weird VR project do
let me know these are the deadlines and
my contact Ino thank you very
much so my name is William iio I'm a
professor here in comparative media
studies and principal investigator of
the open doc lab that's that's uh
sponsoring this event and to sort of
segue into our first question it's I
I'll pick up from Jonathan Harris the
Jonathan Harris quote you gave about the
potentials for new language and I want
to start with a a sort of confusing
moment in an old language those of you
who have seen 360 video especially
attempts to tell stories with 360 video
May recognize Buster Keaton's dilemma
here
um you're immersed in a
world it's convincing it's at least as
convincing as the VR can make it and all
of a sudden you're somewhere else like
it or not you're busy exploring
something in this corner of the of this
this side of the uh the VR experience
and the director has decided it's time
for you to go to the next scene and this
strikes me as such an such an apt uh
expression of that dilemma what language
what language should we be using I think
our default mode um has often been to
look back on the traditions we know from
you know welldeveloped over the last
hundred years with Cinema and television
in terms of how we do visual
storytelling but I think certainly in
360 um U VR but also to some extent
beyond that we're kind of we're kind of
fumbling our way through that old
vocabulary into a new one so I I guess
with that it would be maybe a good
question to start with is what kind of
new vocabularies what kind of what kind
of new techniques um are we are we at an
impass with what we're using and or
should we be looking for new kinds of
ways of telling non-fiction stories um I
mean no no you've done it quite well
with what you're doing your soundtracks
tend to really hold things together um
and the visuals make sense accordingly
but what's your sense of this where do
we what do we need to be thinking about
in terms of structure for story in this
space any of you well there's a
technological issue of nausea right
that's a no that's a serious issue to in
this space right it's Unique to this
medium and we have to
address um that as part of the
construction of our pieces so I know
that Ben Solomon who made that really
nice piece displaced was saying that um
there's one shot where people are on a
boat moving or they're on a back of a
Truck moving he said you know 70% of the
people I tell me it's their favorite
shot and another 30% say made them so
nauseous they had to rip the goggles off
so that issue of knowing that where your
eyes feel like you're moving but your
body is not moving that disconnect can
be really problematic for a part of the
audience and I don't know how we're
going to solve that I mean I tend to
lock the camera off I tend to be very
conservative I tend to be not one I let
people move with their bodies that's one
of the reasons why I like the body
embodied stuff because then the body and
the camera are which is your eyes are
connected I do that uh uh in a maybe
conservative way CU some people will say
moving the camera it's fine
um that is something which I think we're
going to find out I mean I've heard some
very
weird possibilities that actually
there's like a an inner ear I don't know
what exactly they're doing but they're
like putting pressing like pushing like
air into the inner ear so that it
creates a pressure system to make you
feel like you're moving when the
camera's moving but like that's a
technological solution and I think that
we as artists should be coming up with
some storytelling Solutions first
I think for us as journalists you know
the thing that we're we're struggling
with is how do you do um especially
investigative journalism in the space
how do you how do you actually transmit
real information we would call
journalism in the space that actually
you can you can actually absorb without
reverting to you know a ton of VoiceOver
which we will use some of but you know
ultimately I feel like we're in the sort
of beta phase for what we're going to do
for journalistic VR in our case um and I
think 8i and some of the experiences
that I've had since actually could
transport us in a way that is frameless
that will help us rethink then how we
can tell stories so I feel like the work
that we're doing is almost you know I'm
speaking just on frontline's behalf
because we've now done four or five big
projects I think we're getting closer
and closer to understanding how you can
get information in and I think the other
thing and I've seen it in some of the
work that you guys have done is how do
you take then 2D images so a lot of the
world that we live in is telling telling
stories that have existed already so if
you're telling if you're telling a story
about you know storm Sandy for example
because we're doing a VR experience
about living through a storm then how do
you take these archival images that are
still in 2D that are still captured in
2D that are real that you want to give a
real sense of the actual incident itself
how do you combine 2D in a 3D
environment or do we have to right so
when you're telling a story that
actually happened and it's not captured
360 or in VR what do you do as a
Storyteller these are the biggest
challenges we have as documentarians in
a space where we want to tell real
stories or we want to transmit you know
deep information and frankly at
Frontline we're used to it so we just
had a a conversation today about the
meaning of this work being more than
just a really cool environment at least
for Frontline right so how do you it's
not to be experimental visually for much
us as much as it is how do we take you
inside a story in a deeper way so you
feel like you're there more and then
you're impacted more
challenging yeah I'll pick up on that as
well actually
um in terms of the challenges I think
one of the things that we've been
learning as we've been working with um
especially with big broadcasters is that
um is that a lot of the conversation is
quite understandably coming from a very
familiar language of of television and
film and um I think the way that we were
is sort of I mean we we we we also come
from that tradition but we all are
trying to kind of bridge the gap to um
understand more about game design and um
and kind of starting from a perspective
of okay my story exists in the body of
the user and what are they doing in this
story that actually tells the narrative
and I'm conveying that to a ITV
commissioner is like it's it's been um
it's an interesting conversation you
know they automatically the question is
always what but what does it look like
and we go but no you want we want people
to do this and they're like yeah but
what when they do that what does it look
like so you know I think those kinds of
conversations are really they are a real
Challenge and it's it's everyone kind of
figuring it all out together I suppose
yeah can I just push the
interinstitutional thing a bit I mean
especially for organizations that are
large Legacy organizations have not done
much VR are interested in it because
it's cool or because it's hot or because
they need to do it because everyone else
is doing it um that's sort of maybe a
top down incentive bottom up you've got
makers who have a project that can
really benefit from this that that needs
VR in a way that a a flat a 2d or maybe
a linear is not going to do the trick
those two pressure points sometimes
don't align in fact I'm willing to bet
they often don't align in some
organizations um any better ways to make
those reconcile
or I think like at Frontline we always
ask should this story be in VR actually
so we're not just doing VR for vr's sake
like we're actually doing it because we
think it could tell a better story we're
working with Nani because we can see
that she'll take us to the next level
when it comes to storytelling so because
we have Frontline already we're doing
linear film they do really well even
digitally these films do great so you
know it's being disciplined actually
about making sure when we're making a
decision that it's a righteous creative
and journalistic decision so it takes
disci and I am a commissioner right so
it does take discipline for somebody
like me to say no no no we're not going
to just do the cool thing that I know is
going to you know get a million people
to see it it's just like what does it
mean should it be VR even I don't think
every story is is meant to be told in
this space you know
frankly yeah I think it's really
encouraging though to see um to see
organizations like that I mean like like
you guys and like the BBC that we work
with um are willing to take a kind of a
gamble in a way especially at this stage
when no one really knows how it's going
to go no one really knows how to
distribute it um the work that we makes
for um for you know Oculus Rift I mean
how many people have their hands on a CV
one right now but the but the the thing
that's
pretty ticking whatever time balm or
whatever that's I think is going to be
super super interesting is when the
morphe is hits in October because if
you've got 40 million plus users who've
got a PlayStation and they can plug in
their Oculus Rift for 300 bucks now
we're sorry Oculus RI sorry uh I'm sorry
mistake Morpheus the Sony Morpheus for
$300 so you've got a audience you know
worldwide of 40 million in which a 300
million sorry $300 God I'm tired I feel
like I came from Australia a $300
headset can get plugged into the
PlayStation VR well that's a major major
distribution pipeline so what then for
story and Sony's a little you know um
you know valve has Steam and steam is
pretty good about letting you upload and
and um Oculus has the share Oculus share
which lets you upload stuff and Sony is
making a sign of rather there even said
let's have your lawyer on the first
phone call because the becoming a
developer for Sony is such a hugely
layered onerous thing so they need the
content I I don't really know what's
going to happen but I can tell you for
somebody like me who's saying wow I'm
going to have access to that kind of
distribution for the you know you know
maybe even bigger than some of the um
broadcasters I worked with right um
that's pretty massive but this is really
I mean this is history repeating itself
for the eenth time the beginning of
every medium has all these format uh D
dilemmas every company is trying to hold
on to its proprietary format and
therefore its distribution uh you know
uh uh they construct their own
distribution bottlenecks and I wonder I
mean on the one hand so we we're dazzled
at festivals with all this great stuff
and then you go out and you buy
something and it doesn't actually work
with um the things you thought were
really cool or you're really
limited is that is there going to be
wisdom this time around on the parts of
the corporations or is this going to be
driven by a user Revolt
the I you should
talk I think young people are going to
drive this frankly like I was thinking
you know during the year I was an open
dock lab fellow um my child my boy was 7
and a half or eight and you remember the
kind of profound conversations I was
having with my children about their
expectation from media so their
certainly their expectation is that it's
an immersive environment first and
foremost they can touch it and feel it
and they can really be in their
environment so I do think that this is
going to happen to us frankly that
people who are experienced PlayStation
who are Gamers already ready they're
going to be driving the expectation for
the work that we do to some degree and I
think the fact and you should weigh in
on this too that Facebook and YouTube
and Google are making such a play for
the space even in a 360 sense right now
with Native players that we're
publishing in and I think Carla boras is
here today she runs VR for us with me
and you know we're really looking at
these new environments to publish
natively in because that's where we
reach them the most number of people so
I I don't know if it's going to repeat
itself I just think that there's a huge
opportunity here I think I think it's
repeating
itself
um I mean there's there's it's which
part of history is it repeating but I
think the difference um if I look 10
years ago when sort of this happened
around web and and and digital art I
think there was the same thing
broadcasters need to like deal with this
thing called the internet and get to the
young people and um I think the great
thing was that the internet was an open
platform even though there was
proprietary stuff like flash but but
there was the internet and it was a
place where everybody basically was very
could could cheaply uh uh play around
and distribute to
everybody and the bad the the great
thing um now is that there's actually
companies needing to sell devices so
there's money there's a hype there's
like big big money going into this
that's why that's the good news the bad
news is there is no web VR or some
people are working on it but it's not I
got an email yesterday yet I got an
emailer sorry
Brian you think it will come I think we
really need it
Brian get it it will no it I think it's
it's um right now it's it's it's really
sort of I mean it's the good and the bad
of it of it right keep we some in the
world keep trying to bottle the genie
stuff it back in and yeah it's it's a
it's a very good point race is another I
mean it's a t itially Rel a point but
it's about ethics in this that um there
are a whole lot of ethical issues the
one that gets talked about a lot is the
is the affect I mean this is an
effective medium or at least is alleged
to be one could argue that literature
and film are also quite effective um but
there are con there are and we'll talk
about this tomorrow with with some
neuroscientists that this is processed
in a slightly different way and may have
different implications on that score we
know that ey tracking is the next big
thing and those eye tracks are going to
be doing more than helping us navigate
and mitigating nausea what happens to
that data I mean Facebook's interest in
this is not is not just about trying to
capture a new market for entertainment
um thoughts on the ethical stance of
things is this a place where we need
where how can we Foster more attention
to this or more debate or sharper sense
of what's happening I think that's you
know it's a key part of the grant that
the Knight Foundation gave uh jointly to
emblematic and Frontline was to try to
come up with some ethical best practices
through this exploration of making
content to try to at least raise the
questions and make sure that they're
front and center that we're we're trying
to R you know Wrangle with these and and
dig deeper into what these issues are um
you know I faced a lot of these
particularly when I started out um
because I was recreating scenes right so
I mean I literally had colleagues
pointing their fingers in at me going
you can't do this this will never work
this isn't journalism that's a game
platform or you know games aren't
Journal ISM I mean it was really I took
a lot of criticism when I began this
process um and I still get a questioned
a lot about whether I'm
ethically uh trying to address the
issues but I think the best we can do is
is make sure that we um raise the
questions and indicate that when we're
making this work at this point that we
aren't ignoring um um the kind of
principles that we have utilized
previously
uh in print and broadcast and
documentary um that have informed our
approach to work and our sensitivities
to the individuals whose stories were
trying to
portray that's like the essence of our
grant which I think is cool because it's
also a maker Grant so we're making three
big projects and we're just we're just
actually for the first time started
really making the first project um this
week and I think out of that we're going
to be asking these really tough
questions of each other and of course we
come much more from the traditional but
so does n so I think it's going to raise
a lot of these questions then we have to
publish some stuff that you'll hopefully
help us
edit and speaking of questions I mean
this we're talking about a fairly
interactive medium it the floor is open
for questions so if you have any come
forward um and meanwhile another
question on my part is simply um and
this certainly happens a lot in the
exhibition space the the festival space
of your but how do we you know it's a
very individual medium closer off from
the world in our little box I guess you
could argue that reading was the same
way um and yet the Cinematic or the
visual part of it and maybe even the
effective part kind of encourages us to
want to be with other people they're
usually around us they're the noise is
coming through the headsets in most
Festival settings um and I know that
this latest generation of the enemy that
will be shown here actually has I think
you can see other I haven't seen it but
I think other figures are in it oh okay
you know if if you have a if you have a
teenage kid and or you know particular
boy I mean if you don't think you're
aren't hearing their friends and coming
out of their bedroom from their TF2 play
that they're not screaming at each other
and you can't hear the other kids coming
through into your house I mean you know
the story I always I mean tell is that
my my son was in the living room with
his laptop open on his lap and my
daughter was in my her garage my garage
office my daughter walked into the
living room my son looked up from the
laptop I went why'd you leave but she
just walked in the room and what he
meant was why' you leave the Minecraft
silver we were playing on together right
I mean shared shared experiences may not
be necessarily sitting next to each
other with the stuff on shared
experiences the places that we go
together and virtual spaces will
classrooms come together to um I mean
when I did virtual the virtual go t Bay
prison in in Second Life that was a very
interesting for me uh moment where I
would show up at our virtual build and
there'd be classrooms from Canada
comeing to expect the virtual GMO
because they couldn't actually look at
the real one right so um and there you
know people I didn't know and it would
be would be coming in all the time so
um that kind of experience I think it's
going to end up being more common um but
in in in as we start to be able to scan
our world like you guys are in the field
is amazing um as we're able to bring
people in and do this very interesting
volumetric capture um the embodied you
know right now when you jump at the
movies it's it's going to be a different
kind of jumping and you'll be jumping
with your friends but just maybe not
sitting next to each other I I would
agree I think that's definitely where
we're going but I would actually
question whether um you know you say
that um when you're in a festival
environment you actually do want to kind
of be in the headset and share your
experience I I mean personally I don't
you know like I actually think we
shouldn't be scared of the fact that it
is an individual thing and um sometimes
that's it's a blessed relief you know
you get in there and oh you know like I
don't have to to we we're I think it it
says something to the way that we um are
kind of training to communicate these
days that everything is collective right
and we kind of expect that to be the way
that things should be but I mean just
speaking personally I think that um
there is some element of of me that goes
ah I actually don't have to do that
while I'm here so I think we should
embrace that it's interesting how we
talk about the definition of what PR is
even though it's it's not defined yet
and I think let's embrace the fact that
it's still undefined in that sense
because what you're describing is some
of my favorite VR experiences what
you're describing is some of the little
VR multi-user things that I've seen so
far that really excite me they're both I
don't know if it's VR I don't care like
it's it's both immersive art or
immersive experiences solitary and
non-solitary
we can have interactive theater and non
interactive C and eat it
too thank you all is this
testing okay hi thank you all this is a
great panel my name is Dan Roy I'm a
cmsm hi William um I Love Actually your
last comment about the VR is undefined
because I agree in five years we won't
have a conference on VR we'll have a
conference on all of the subsets and you
know the the experience of Google
cardboard versus you know the Vive is so
completely different opposite ends of
the spectrum one is seated and you have
to hold your hands to your face the
other you're moving around the
room some of you talked about
inclusivity there's a tension between
you know the reach of the Google
cardboard or PlayStation 4 versus some
of these experiences that may be more
immersive or may track more aspects of
your body in the space but maybe enable
us to do more with that Medium how do
you balance the tension between
exploring the potential of the medium
that you're interested in with the
Mandate of the organization you come
from to reach whatever your target
audience is thank you can I I think it's
it's if we ask that question to a medium
like print we would say there's really
expensive popup books being made or
there's really expensive coffee table
books that you really devote your entire
attention to and there's news papers and
there's comics and there's short stories
and there's poetry like I think VR can
be all those things um if you're making
something for the Vive it's like making
experience for like first of all the
Vive asks of people to devote a room to
a thing it's like buying an entire
physical pool table and putting it in
your house the experience must be really
really special to to like uh um to live
up to that uh for the cardboard I think
we're totally looking more at Social
experiences we're totally looking at
quick experiences where it's a much more
versatile medium just like a newspaper
is much more versatile but it does yield
two radically different VR experiences
one is good for 360 video and one one
has incredible different set of of
affordances
so VI like having a TV in your home it
doesn't really require too much more
space you can have you can just have a
your TV room right now is very easily
convertible to uh A vibe space you don't
not need a huge amount of room to walk
around so um just to say may maybe my
Heist is too
small your house is big enough you just
have to kick the baby's crib you know
out the into the hallway for a a little
bit
sorry I was just going to say I mean for
a Frontline in public television I think
that one of the most important things is
that we we do survive so one of the
parts of surviving is being brave and
looking at new stories form I really do
believe and that's not just VR that's
also across interactive storytelling and
also just natively publishing on other
platforms and I think that's part of our
mandate is to continue to try to do
really high quality work as it pertains
to VR I was really excited by the fact
that we can look at how this can be more
widely available even if the experience
isn't as amazing as Vibe and and some of
the really incredible VR experiences
I've had but just to give people a
cinematic 60 experience is an entry way
into understanding this space that I
think is important and then people have
more access to it so at Frontline
because we are public television and
we're public media we have to make this
available so people can access it so
it's available to the public and I know
the barrier is going to become much much
much less expensive even still for the
for the more immersive experience so we
are doing both in all frankly yeah I
think from an indie producers point of
view
again we have we're in the same position
we get asked we kind of pitch in at the
at the highest quality we want and then
um are we often having to do things like
version the work for um for a broader
distribution
platform hi um thanks for a great panel
um Phil Gara I recently graduated from
MIT saloan um I had this weird moment at
the Tribeca film festivals VR exhibit
where it basically I was handed a menu
of VR items to look from and they were
all um stories of human suffering in
some way and I I kind of felt weird just
like being like okay I'm going to pick
this one out of famine um so I'm
wondering you know what what you guys
make of this kind of trend that seems to
have captured early VR this focus on
human suffering um and and despair and
yeah I wonder what you make of it and I
wonder um you know why that's become so
popular and if if um that same kind of
power for suffering can be used in in
other way I think I think a lot of
people gravitated to the concept that
virtual reality does offer um a
connection that that creates empathy in
the audience and um I think um there's
been certainly a perception that the
audience has been become disconnected
has become um you know there since is D
to important stories around the world
that for some reason they've been
overloaded with images and therefore
they stopped caring about their world so
I think that people who did care and do
care really gravitated to the fact that
maybe they could create an empathy In
Their audience that could help um bring
focus and as I always say um with
younger audiences particular to make
sure they um are informed Global
Citizens about their world so it's not
as if the news organizations don't
always approach these issues and perhaps
they seem focused because there's only
you can't find the comic section in in
VR very yet um and right now it's mostly
focused on the um the stories that are
um you know would be more the front page
stories in a way you know um
yet I think that that that that the
approach is you know it it does seem
like are we going to see another Refugee
story right we're getting that that
overload which we were talking about
before and yet when you go in and you
actually put the goggles on you
experience with stories you go it's
really not just another story it is as
important as the last one um so I think
that's the balance like how do you make
sure that we have a comic section but
make sure we continue to be able to make
the really important stories that touch
people maybe to add to that I
think I think at this point we don't
really dis dis between journalism and
documentary and art and I think if I
look at film
um I mean that very same comment can be
made of uh the documentary film world
where and I've always found that
slightly awkward working for a film
festival where everybody would like line
up to see that amazing film about other
people suffering and then have beers
afterwards and go dancing and I think
there is a deeply strange thing
happening there and it deals with
physical or like the the um it's strange
that we need media to have like stories
from other people's suffering and we're
completely disconnected from that uh and
there's this sort of Catch 22 where like
it gives us access to that and makes us
feel something and at the same time
we're just observers and I think in VR
same thing we're just observers and
sometimes even worse so uh because when
the medium becomes
interactive it's actually asking me to
do something something and to partake in
that story somehow and I think it's when
it's done right it's it's some like it
can be incredibly visceral like the
enemy uh for me like made me feel what
it is to be a tall white dude standing
in front of a tiny little
Palestinian guy who's going through
immeasurable suffering that I can never
even understand and I actually felt how
I how distant I was from him in a way
that a film would never do a film I
would blame the the filmmaker for not
doing making the right film here I was
like actually I'm standing there and I'm
actually not caring so much like why am
I not why am I walking around this space
instead of listening to him um I think
the other thing is I what I really hope
and what I've always been doing with do
clab is look for interactive stories
that where the thing that the user
brings makes the story and I think
looking at suffering is is not a great
thing to bring uh but like diving deep
into yourself or like exploring how
mundanely like how intensely boring your
life is can be a incredibly dramatic
experience if like in an interactive
piece you do that right like that
question that the the robot asks you all
sorts of questions that's like really
everyday life stuff but really intense
and I would love to see more of that um
in and yet Ry I would suggest to you I
mean investigative
storytelling it's crucial it's crucial
totally totally but that's why I'm
saying like that's there there's a part
journalism and there's a part like
documentary and art and just like we
have poetic documentaries that show us
the beauty of a landscape but the part
about right I was I was gonna say
actually because this question the very
same question came up at another
conference a couple of days ago where
somebody said are we at risk for
stereotyping even in this environment so
they took it to another level and um I
said well for Frontline you know we have
the saying where the trouble with so
it's sort of what we do right like we we
actually unpack investigative stor so
our hope is we're not just bringing you
human suffering but we're actually
investigating it so at the end you you
don't feel as hopeless that's the whole
point to Frontline right and that I just
we haven't cracked it yet in VR right
it's more immersive than our films are
but I just have to believe that we're
going to be able to crack this code Cod
so you don't feel as hopeless and sort
of depressed after or or um like you
said maybe you even feel distant from it
and like you don't care and you don't
know why you don't care so I think it's
a great question I mean I think there's
an underlying one one of the great
things with VR done well is that um
there's a tension between that feeling
of being there where you you know as you
just said you're there you're you're
empathetic in ways that you probably
could distance yourself from with other
media that you're more familiar with and
at the same time you're you're watching
there's your you're you're a Voyer
there's nothing you could do and and to
find a way to sort of exploit that
tension to to direct that tension into
action would be really that's what the
enemy does in a way and yeah the enemy I
have to say of of um yeah don't miss it
if you haven't signed up uh don't miss
it it really is I haven't seen this
version but that I think that question
as a Storyteller always is an issue
because you get to walk away at the end
of the day Y and that is something which
if you're you know if you're sensitive
to that issue it carries through your
work from beginning to
end hi hi there uh so I'm Amy Starling
I'm the director of iwire it's a brain
mapping game crowdsource neuroscience
and I'm a huge fan of VR and to kind of
springboard off that last question I
think virtual reality has this huge
tremendous potential for Wonder and awe
right like you can see things that you
could never otherwise experience and as
someone who works in science and
technology I'm always looking for more
VR experiences that say tell the the
history of invention or you know the
evolution of neuroscientific discoveries
you know you could be in Isaac Newton's
lab and so I would just love to hear you
guys' thoughts on kind of the the future
of you know telling stories of Discovery
and maybe even data visualization or
that that realm of VR just got asked by
a friend who's a Quantum physicist uh to
help visualize a a 12 Dimension project
that they're working on I'm like please
let me please let me get a crack at that
like how amazing fun will that be so um
I agree I think it's really really
interesting because they kind of talk
about their lab in the sort of non you
know normal way and I you know can
barely wrap my head you know I don't
think I can wrap my head around it I
didn't think that would be aive I can
say barely but the idea of getting to
think about VR is a place that we can
start to visualize things that are you
know otherwise unimaginable literally to
most of the world it's really exciting I
think you're absolutely right um
microscopically we're working with um a
scientist uh who turned artist in um
Switzerland who does uh microscopic uh
you microelectron imagery of Might and
he makes these incredibly beautiful
images of the world of the might and um
you know I keep laughing my poor team
keep me what do you mean you want to
make a love story about might but like
you know you know that's it right we can
do things like that that understand live
in their world in a way that is so
beautiful and different and again
unimaginable and I think that's one of
the really exciting parts of VR one of
the people on our team Carla is always
saying like if she was a kid today
learning science like how totally
amazing it would be if people could put
their their minds to how we could teach
with this form which I know you have
someone speaking about tomorrow which I
think is one of the most amazing tools
and the other work that's really
impressive is work that's being done at
POV um and they do a lot of interactive
storytelling but some of their most
dramatic work has been in data
visualization which they've been
starting to think about VR and I just
think some of the data visualizations
they've done have so much potential in
that 3D space as well which is cool
there's a project in the exhibition
tomorrow called lovr by Aron
Bry which isn't technically scientific
uh it's inspired on neuro
uh scientific data on what happens when
you fall in love so it's basically you
go it's a data Vis project where you go
through sort of fly through a timeline
of a sort of slow down the the moment
when somebody falls in love at first
sight um and you should check it
out thank
you so um thank you very much um my name
is Andre I study um synesthesia as an
inclusive
practice and in the context of what we
were just talking about
um in um in the context of learned
helplessness and this sort of acquired
apathy that
um if we're not very careful whether it
can be generated um through uh VR and I
think it's this Gap that we have where
VR is more uh more immersive than it is
interactive um and um in the context of
this I'm wondering how would how except
from like the technology of
interaction
um how do we profile the processes
of
imagination in the VR
space
question that's really deep I can tell
you what I think have many of you done
to brush yep have any painted here with
tiltbrush
very do you not feel like that's the
process of imagination right there we'
that that's a virtual reality painting
program right one of the first ones
where you paint in 3D and uh in colors
and you can throw snowflakes up and they
fall on you so I've had a lot of people
demo that piece and it kind of has
astonished me
the way that people engage with that
piece I I have to take the headset off
and I've had you know accountants come
in and go well I'm really not creative
and then they can't believe what they
can make and it seems to me it gets to
this
basic thing I don't know I I've decided
I've decided this is in my very
anecdotal observation that humans need
to make and it's no more more evident
than in this virtual reality program
that that is so so wildly different and
I see people just don't want to stop
making so there is something there I
don't I you know I I wouldn't uh want to
go uh much further than that since it's
purely an anecdotal observation but it's
an anecdotal observation of hundreds and
hundreds of people now um uh so if you
can go ahead and do to rush and you can
start doing your own investigation I
think it's a great tool for that agreed
I'll just add to that I think that um
that your point about vity being more
immersive than interactive is probably
true at the moment but that's that's it
doesn't have to be like that you know
and I think that is our job as artists
and storytellers to kind of try if we
want to push it in that direction we
need to to start from a place of
interactivity from starting from that
okay what what what is um how do I tell
my story through operation you know
rather than how do I put it in front of
your eyes so you can look around in it
um and I think once we start to think in
that way we will be starting to kind of
get to that place where
we're producing more engaging stories
that have um that have doing as part of
their very kind of bones their
day thank you very much uh my name is
bester grah I'm a filmmaker and I'm uh
taken by how often we're referring to
this as an immersive medium and refer
and yet the examples that we're giving
are essentially visual examples in terms
of the immersion knowing that actually
audio is so much a part of emersion so
I'm curious about uh how you're thinking
about audio sound uh the whole
challenges that are we're faced with
that uh VR will be actually changing in
terms of the space that we go into with
it and a very early piece that we did at
the uh lab of Mel Slater in Barcelona
who's one of the earliest fura
researchers who I did my first uh uh you
know big wide five those go those
$50,000 goggles that's where I worked um
and we did a piece where we put you in a
body a detain in a stress position um
where you first you saw this character
in a stress position and then you had a
virtual mirror and it mirrored every one
of your movements I was trying to look
at what does it really mean all these
Freedom of Information Act reports that
a detain would put in a stress position
for hours on end what did that what was
that really like what did that really
mean beyond the words on a paper but
anyway we did an interrogate we used the
interrogation log of Al katani who the
Bush Administration said was tortured so
there's no doubt what had happened to
the guy and we use an actor to read the
interrogation logs and it was meant to
come through another room and they
played it I was not yet I was still in
LA and I was flying to Barcelona and
they were testing it on people and they
played it right next to people and I had
done the audio recording with the idea
was going to come through another room
so the audio was muffled and weird and
wrong and people were not having a very
good connection to this case right once
we moved it back through the wall then
everybody we we we had this experience
we they were sitting U right in a chair
with their arms behind their back like
this and we'd ask them what was your
body like afterwards well when the audio
was right they all reported being
hunched over in a stress position they
took on the body of this guy in the
mirror um but without the audio working
they had none of that connection so that
was like immediately one of the first
things I learned was that audio was the
most crucial part of the experience we
were just today at Frontline talking
about our project how do we solve the
audio problem for something that we're
filming and the interesting thing from
where I said is a lot of our filmmakers
have been stripping back their sound
people as production budgets have been
shpping have been shrinking so we're yet
again saying sound matters so much and
you know this bester the the production
dollars have gone down for film making
so then introducing again the fact of
needing surround sound really right well
we know too that uh even if the
picture's bad we'll watch it if the
sound is good it's it's really huge this
this is a a lesson from interactive
documentary as well that some of the
best interactive documentaries actually
started with the sound and then all the
interactive visual everything else uh
came after I think you're showing notes
on blindness here aren't you one of my
favorite favorite pieces that's been
made recently it's called notes on
blindness so if you can see that here
and it's basically somebody's a journey
into um a it's literally somebody's
recording his own Journey becoming blind
and then they've done visuals on top but
in this way that the sound is so his
voice and his experience it's just it's
extraordinary it's funny to I mean a
year ago they showed me the that project
wasn't started as a VR piece which I
still love just goes to show how early
days this is like a year ago they had
like the the demo of the iPad version
and then we're like should we do this
for a VR and now it's like one of the
classics already like an instant class
brilliant wonderful amazing piece
hi my name is Jacob lonstein I'm a grad
student at the Sloan school and I run
our student VR Community here at MIT um
media historically you hear of times
when the Vanguard of a new medium will
talk about how on the previous medium or
the one before that um there was some
experience some story where you know
here or she wanted to feel it more or
perhaps that the narrative ran up
against the boundaries of expression of
that Medium you know I could read
Richard III but I couldn't hear Richard
III and I'm curious you know as artists
yourselves if there are experiences from
older media that you look to that sort
of have inspired you in VR because they
run up against the limitations of the
medium through which they were expressed
or even relatedly if there are ones you
look to to learn to learn from for
example do look to gaming to learn from
how you know previous artists have
handled interactivity element such as
that yeah I mean to answer that half of
my my staff are from the games the games
world we work with game developers game
artists um and we're learning as much
from them as as anything else um I think
that you know it's from for our
company's perspective we do take a lot
of inspiration from lots and lots of
different places I know I mean Oscar is
an artist I training so we talk a lot
about painting about sculpture um when
we're doing our concept designs for our
pieces um or we've got our entire staff
with who are from the games World um and
you know we we've kind of named our
company after Zig verto sorry we kind of
thought we kind we're not um adverse to
experimentation in in thought and form I
suppose I mean I think for the first
time frontlines looking at interactive
storytelling mostly in the gaming space
I mean and even with our first couple of
projects we were actually so just nent
stages that we would have to go around
the room and understand the makers from
secret location in this in this um
situation what do you do who are you
what do you make and then they would
show us their their native computer
language and then we would learn from
that so we've had to really look at
other story forms to understand how to
start to tell stories in this way and
yet of course good stories are good
stories right and that's not anything
new you desperately you know um always
need to be absorbing good stories to
think about how to construct good
stories so um and certainly all the
visual stuff I mean there's of course
Lighting in games there Lighting in
films how do you do Lighting in VR um
and that's in itself a real challenge
when people are moving around a real
time way um so trying to think about how
did how did how did
Big I tell you what I like to look a lot
at I actually have these really
beautiful Old Stage design books um and
um from like all 50s through the 80s and
um there's some beautiful stuff because
now yes the stage used to be there and
yes you're now you're in the middle of
the stage but the way that that some of
the approach was for that kind of space
that you're in I find it really
inspiring yes I think there's some I
think one of the things of like how New
Media affect old media like how look how
photography affected painting like
painting became a more exclusive much
more like abstract art came as a result
of painting maybe even uh or abstract
painting um I think it's really
interesting to look at like what was
really Niche back when old media were
mainstream like what was really
happening on The Fringe of Opera at the
time when Opera was the main thing like
what was happening in like experimental
cinema at the time when Cinema was the
main thing maybe it's still this I don't
know but um I think that's really
interesting like I look a lot at
performance art at like audio to or art
like really sort of art forms that use
very basic uh tools that we all have
today but um that never reached a sort
of mainstream level and now through VR
and the hype of VR it's actually really
interesting to see how I don't know some
of those earlier masterpieces now can be
reinvented hi um I'm Margo Ferris I'm a
graduate student with MIT and I'm also a
science correspondent with story bench
which is an under the hood um look at
digital storytelling and sort of the
Innovative things are coming out of that
right now um and some things we like to
ask are um advice for incoming
journalism students so my question for
you is um do you have any advice for um
students wanting to get into VR or this
sort of immersive storytelling whether
they're in journalism or they're in game
design or they're in um
programming so we just had this great
experience with nyu's um journalism and
Film School where the we ended up
working with the team who did this great
work out of Chernobyl and actually I
think the best advice I could give is
learn the technology learn how to use
the cameras learn how to actually edit
and understand it enough because for
someone like me to work with students is
completely exciting if you're bringing
to to us skills that you know are not
natively cooked into frontlines
producing core at this point right so if
you come through the door really with
some skills that we don't have have you
will be welcome trust me so I would I
would get some very specific answers to
that question which is I've got audio um
which is that um you know they should
learn uh a stitching software for they
want to do 360 video cinematic VR they
want to learn um some crucial they want
to do stitching some editing Premiere um
there's things like Auto panel that can
help uh The Foundry is about to release
a tool that auto stitches um so these
are some very specific um uh uh oh my
gosh my brain is telling on the audio
tool I can't believe it uh oh well so
it's pretty easy to find with 360 video
so there sort of four key things you
really need to know for 360 video is is
going to be um you know your stitching
um your Premiere editing uh your audio
tool and then think about how do you
bring that into a game engine and you
have some compositing which also Foundry
makes another tool called nuke and what
the what the what the a what the um
compositing does is when you've got two
cameras shooting and there's some sort
of overlap maybe or an underlap and
you've got to do something about fixing
that you use a tool called nuke to to
kind of uh manipulate the digital
information to kind of basically put a
Band-Aid on the in a very pretty way on
the on the problem where the shooting is
when you go into kinematic VR the tool
sets a little bit different and can be
more complex um then you get into tools
like Maya
motion Builder certainly all these game
engine helps Unity unreal sorry I like
to give this list for people so it's not
so mysterious um unity and unreal are
the two game engines that you use uh and
um um I mean honestly if you can get a
little Maya and a little unreal under
your belt you can go really far with um
uh kinematic VR and then some of the
scanning stuff what do you guys use what
do you you tell your tools iPad and a
structure sensor and there you can buy
those for I think $600 yeah they're very
affordable so my advice to would be just
do it you know um it's kind of a freefor
all at the moment lots of people can
make the barriers to entry are low and
um and if you get out there and make
something you're an expert you know it's
interesting because um's this song can
you hear me okay oh there we go U no
it's interesting because you know it's a
very collaborative field you mentioned
you've worked with um people in other
disciplines um but so it's interesting
with um you know students coming into
this for the first time where they can
learn like the um software you were
mentioning but then also how um you know
some of these headsets cost hundreds of
dollars like you know getting access to
that as well so um do you have any
thoughts on that how can can I add one
more thing now I've given that list of
tools yeah sure I always tell people the
first place to start is just to close
your eyes and feel your body in the
space before you make the story and you
because that's more like what vr's like
your body's in the space so what does it
feel like and I think that's a really
before you begin writing writing your
story or thinking about your story what
does it mean to be in the middle of it
sorry please finish your question how do
you get access to the tools I know
that's a lot of the software is great I
mean Unity totally helped create this
whole VR wave because they I used a free
game engine software for a long time and
I I am so grateful to my YouTube C
teachers so I learned my coding on on on
mostly on YouTube um from YouTube um so
that part is a pretty easy thing it's
true getting the headsets is a little
bit harder but um here's the interesting
thing you'd be surprised like um a lot
of the headset manufacturers made some
first versions and they made a lot of
those first versions and they're not as
good as the latest versions and there
going to be a lot of people getting rid
of the older headsets I guarantee you
and that's going to be a lot cheaper for
people to have access to them so I bet
they can start looking on a Marketplace
like that I was actually surprised at
the NYU students and how low their
budget was we can share with you you
know like a short list of the equipment
that they had because they were able to
construct something pretty affordably
and they talk The Faculty into buying it
so get some people on your side you know
in positions of power to buy stuff and
it's usually I mean they really gave us
a lower budget for what they bought as
the entry point you know and that's just
to start
experimenting
thanks hi um my my name is Gabriella ARP
and I'm actually kind of like on the
next stage of her question I'm
graduating from UNCC Chapel Hill and um
for my thesis project I did a a
cinematic virtual reality film that I'm
finishing in post- production now and um
yeah and so I had access to the camera
through the school and I had access to
Grants that let me travel to the
location of the filming and so now I'm
kind of entering um postgraduation life
which is obviously scary
um and I guess my question is beforehand
I was a freelance
filmmaker um if you see this industry is
becoming something like uh you know for
Katie you started your own production
company um but how Freelancers uh fit
into that scene I think there's a big
place for Freelancers at the moment um
again coming back to the the space that
everyone's kind of interested in this
few people are experimenting I mean more
and more but but you know you're going
to be in a very good position if you've
already made something to go out there
and and you know and get hired as a
freelance um 360 videographer I would
say um we use in in so in my workflow
we're not we're not in 360 video but we
use a lot of Freelancers from the game
industry so we're you know I would say
that our structure is very similar to
any other small um media company we we
kind of expand and contract as projects
kind of come about um yeah
yeah I mean I think in our world the
world of um mostly linear documentary as
we're trying to expand in VR you would
be well you probably wouldn't be
surprised but we get thousands of
pitches for linear films for for our
series but we get very few um really
solid people coming through the door
like she was just saying you know that
really know what they're doing and
construct a story so you be surprised
how skills are right now yeah I mean
don't undersell your skills as you're
graduating it's kind of awesome that you
decided to do this considering this is
the the part of our world that's
expanding at the moment when when when
the UN says that it's telling the world
that I think they got like a I'm going
to really misquote the number but at
least 30% they went around with a a VR
film and they they were trying to get
people to donate to a cause and they'd
show them the 30 the film and they had
like a crazy 50% or something increase
of donations after the VR film so like
all the NGS are interested in show and
having making VR films and they're just
not enough makers at this point out
there um that's just one market already
growing and then n on on that note when
you were talking about kind of um the
different platforms that you're using do
you guys have any recommendations for
gear because it's changing so rapidly if
I don't want to invest in gear like
where to rent gear from or there is the
million-dollar question uh yeah that's
yeah I know we we've we've we've
compiled list and then we changed that
list and we put another list and we've
got another list and so you know um uh
if you want me to share with you our
list and our and our research um I'll
tell you what we have together for um uh
pros and cons and um really we should
put this Google up do up right and then
and then and then people can decide for
themselves but um at least you'll have a
kind of list of the take the research
we've done and maybe make it uh usable
for uh and and valuable for other people
to make some decisions on their own
anybody here have a recommendation on a
camera by the
way okay yeah it's it's open it's a
really open field actually it's
hilarious because in the night Grant
we're supposed to be buying gear
together and we can't decide so we're
still trying to figure it out because
there something coming in two weeks two
weeks mon Na and everybody says
something it's all easier but is it as
good anyway right so we we'll probably
just buite the bullet and buy a couple
things that we think might be good
enough and then see which one works best
but um you everybody's shooting with
GoPro Briggs right now and they are good
and terrible um uh uh but um but um uh
as as we compiled this list that we've
been putting together and um we should
share with
you thank
you so I've got one last I don't see
anyone else waiting so we'll we'll uh
but it it's you know we've been talking
a lot about VR and we've been looking
and all of you make sort of um projects
that stand on their own two feet maybe
rainy you're the exception um because
another way to look at this as as part
of a media Ensemble there's more and
more crossplatform work where each
medium can kind of pull its weight do
what it does best and VR obviously has a
clear place in that in that uh
constellation is that certainly with
organizations like the New York Times
that's the foreseeable future VR can
bring things to stories it can bring
attention to stories that might
otherwise get it um how do you see that
evolving staying that way more ically
cross media more division of labor I I
think that this type of Storytelling
will just grow as it pertains to you
know current affairs or journalism I
think more and more people are
passionate about it and doing it I was
actually with the New York Times um this
guy named Sam doick this week and we
were on a panel together and he's great
he said they're they're going to start a
whole strand they're calling meditation
VR so to the point of just you know
desperate depressing situations they're
trying to find a more meditative
storytelling form
I think for places that are documentary
series or broadcasters we absolutely are
going to keep expanding but it'll be
part of a whole swath of things that we
do it doesn't have to mean that linear
film goes away or that writing goes away
and and I just think it's another way of
telling a story and it can be very
persuasive and very important but it
doesn't have to be the answer the only
answer we have we have a book on our
Shelf at home that's uh was published in
2005 and it's it said it's on the
history of the book and the and the just
the death jacket cover says uh boy this
book is more important than ever now
that books are going away well I exactly
laughable a decade later that's a
laughable claim right books are not
going away but VR is but VR is a
fantastically interesting space to
create in okay last question um so we've
talked a little bit about uh the labor
that's involved in this and uh in
traditional linear entertainment as uh
crew sizes have gotten smaller you've
gotten down to Predators who now do two
three four jobs in where there used to
be five or six people right um what I'm
hearing though in the creation of this
though is that you actually are
expanding staffs back out now
traditional entertainment is Contracting
as a business you guys have yet to
really establish a business model for VR
doesn't really exist yet how do we get
past this what are you know this is the
million-dollar question or billion
dollar question
really how do the economics work the
economics not sure be the last question
I'm not sure if the business models for
other forms of documentary work uh as
flawlessly is wonderful thank you but
that's I mean it's it's funny like I
mean this is this question I think is
always like the the question that we get
at the festival like what's the business
model and for 10 years of doing like
interactive documentar like but what is
the business
model model no no okay can't produce
Television right now because it doesn't
cost too much money and here we are and
want to do passion projects and really
great storytelling and art yet it's
going to be much more expensive to do it
in this format than it is to do it in
traditional I can tell you how what my
studio surviving which is we're doing
the vertov model actually and we're
making some stuff for
Brands vertov made a few commercial lday
didn't he and that's what we're doing
we're we're making some stuff for for
some major um major major brands um most
of it's kind of fun because um they sort
of are like you know they haven't done
this before so you can kind of do
whatever you want and they're happy um
so it's a pretty fun time to be working
for Brands I don't know how long that
will last but it certainly helping us um
um we have to major major brands we're
working with and I don't know even know
how that happened but but it's happening
because we're an expert right I've been
doing
this it's a joke right it's a joke but
because I've never made anything for
Brands before but now I can make things
for Brands anyway um uh uh the deal is
that's it seems to me I feel like the
what we're establishing in our company
is very similar to the traditional
models of the way that news media
organizations have worked previously we
are making hard news which we love we
are making some funny stuff we're making
some science stuff we are making some
branded sponsored content to help fund
so that to me is the way that in the
long term in the big picture and I know
that isn't really answering your
question how I as an individual go out
and make my project and raise the money
to do it I get that that's the pain
point right now and I've have been there
as you know 700 bucks for for Hunger I
had wow I had a big $35,000 to make
project Sy in 6 weeks and then take it
to the world's economic form and show it
to billionaires holy so I feel your
pain but um you know we just made the
pieces and I think that um you know
that's always the pain of an artist I
think you answered it's hustling I think
is the answer right well maybe to add
one more I'm not sure if this is helpful
but we did a very sort of small
research uh attempt last year at looking
looking at like how we're interactive uh
documentary projects funded this is sort
of pre VR but um and the like projects
from the last was it eight years or so
and out of that came that the the
average budget of a project was
200,000 um but if we looked at the
distribution of the budgets per project
there was actually not a single project
made for that budget like they were all
made for like0 to 100
or they were made for like 300 and up so
that's basically shows that either you
work for nothing or you work with like
you do it yourself or you work with a
brand and you have a big big budget and
and I would encourage just because we're
public media we actually have to keep
our budgets conservative and we care
about keeping things affordable so we're
not going to be able to do this very
often if we can't get the controls down
on the costs right I think it's really
important to collaborate so I would look
at who you can collaborate with because
that's a lot of what we're doing right
now is we're going to other news
organizations and other individuals who
are making things and we're putting
teams together across multiple
organizations and we do it all the time
and it has taken our cost down
dramatically so universities or other or
other journalism entities or whatever
you're really interested in um
editorially you know look to see how you
can partner CU then it can get your
entry in but then also take your cost
down but we absolutely have to do this
or this is not this is almost a Folly
for public media this very specifically
like this is this is a place where
there's a lot of innovation and the
Innovative tools are going to need the
content to Showcase them for example
we're we're we're in the middle of we're
getting towards the end of really
beautiful discussions with ADI which
just raised millions of dollars about to
do their B raise is is series B so
they're getting a lot of money um we
don't have that kind of money you know
we're still content maker um but they're
going to offer us um a stage and support
and um we're going to work on a
journalism platform together which is
super exciting so here's a company that
they need somebody to Showcase their um
tool set um and um you know but you know
I have to tell you there are other other
companies like them a couple other
companies out there for sure but these
guys are a few blocks away from me about
journalism which is really unusual for
one of these big companies one of these
tech companies to actually say
journalism is their priority or one of
their priorities for us was completely
an extraordinary experience and let me
tell you we've had a lot of phone calls
where it's clear that that's not the
company's real priority so finding those
those partners and but you're I feel
like you're here at a place where
there's such cool incubation happening I
would think that this would be one place
where you'd find people making the kind
of tools to help you that that need you
to Showcase their tools yeah actually
the project that we just did at Tribeca
was a a research collaboration with the
BBC and with a bunch of universities so
they actually developed the audio tools
that we we ended up using and they had
they you know that brought the cost of
the whole project right down because we
had the whole soundscape already made
for us um so yeah it's I think
collaboration is is the way to go it's
affordable and it's an audience Builder
it's a great way to bring people to a
story that might not otherwise have
found it so it's just a win-win win hey
with that I'd like to thank our panel
and uh you guys as
well
and hope to see a lot of you over the
next two days thanks
you